hey what is up guys I'm QB HD here and
the idea for this video came from a
bunch of test footage I shot so it's a
little bit short but I really like the
footage so I wanted to upload it anyway
or at least include it in the video so
this is everything you need to know
about open-back headphones there are
only really two types of headphones and
if you're in the market to make a
decision it's a pretty good idea to
understand the basic differences between
the two so there's closed back
headphones and open-back headphones so
most headphones you'll see are closed
back and that's because most of us
listen to headphones to just hear our
music and not anything else so whether
we're on a commute or we're working out
or whatever we're doing listening music
we just want to hear the audio and not
our environment so closed back
headphones do this by creating a seal
around your ear to isolate the noise and
separate the inside from the outside a
couple months ago I did a video on my
top 5 favorite headphones under 200
bucks those were all closed back
headphones and I still stand by that
list by the way that's still like some
of my favorite headphones for the price
so you've probably heard by now one of
the headphones on my list which was the
audio technica ath em 50s M stands for
monitor and they are closed back
headphones so they will isolate your
inside audio from your outside
environment but in a studio or in some
other quiet solo listening environment
you don't need that isolation between
yourself and the outside noise because
there is no outside noise so that's when
you might explore open-back headphones
so open back as the name implies means
the back of the headphones are literally
open there's no barrier between the
drivers and the outside world so
sometimes in some pairs you can actually
see straight through from the inside to
the outside of the headphones if you
shine enough light through this of
course has its main pros and cons the
main pro is normally in the way it
sounds you'll typically have a much more
natural sound where it sounds like the
music is coming from the room around you
instead of being played into your head
this is what's called a wider soundstage
where essentially the stronger this
effect is the more it'll sound like the
sound is coming from further away from
you the more separation there is so it
might sound like the guitar is back
there and the drums are over here and
the bass is over there and the vocals
are up there it can be really immersive
and that's pretty cool and another thing
that can be considered either a pro or
con is that real world sound gets mixed
in with your audio sound so
and back you get room noise as opposed
to just a totally silent isolated noise
from closed back so you'll feel like you
can snap along with the music and hear
yourself snapping you can have a
conversation with the person next to you
as if they're sitting in the room and
they can't hear your music but you can
still hear them if they talk to you it's
pretty interesting again that could be a
pro or con but the real downside of open
back is definitely sound leak because
there's no barrier between the inside
and the outside the vibration of the
diaphragm pushes audio both inward and
outward so if someone's sitting next to
you it'll sound like you're wearing mini
speakers on your head or something
they'll ibly hear everything you're
listening to in a studio or alone this
might not be such a big deal but if
you're trying to listen to music in a
public place like in a gym or on a bus
or really anywhere that's going to be a
little weird that everyone can hear
exactly what song you're listening to
these are the audio technica ath our 70
X the R stands for reference and you can
see it says on the box they're
professional open bag headphones
of course there are other features that
make them more professional grade
headphones like the design and the
material choice and they have removable
cables but really it's the open back
design that makes the real difference in
sound versus the m-series these are the
Sennheiser HD 800 s and they sound
incredible and they are legitimately
professional headphones and they are
also open back and a lot of the highest
end reference headphones you'll find the
ones designed for studio use are open
back for these reasons you're listening
to it in the studio by yourself and a
quiet listening environment but note you
don't have to go super high budget to
get some nice open back headphones
there's a company called grotto actually
I've talked about them before no one's
paid me to say this but they make some
pretty awesome lower priced open-back
headphones so they make open back and
close back but I'll leave a link to
grottoes stuff below there sr ad is or
one of my favorites a couple years ago
there is also something called semi open
back headphones but you really won't see
too much of those so now you guys
basically know all the differences
between open back and closed back and
all of their pros and cons so there you
have it thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed something or learn something and
I'll talk to you guys the next one bass
you